Oda seems to have this idea that one
piece is going to end in the next few
years but when we look at all the
unanswered questions still left in the
story I think he might be a little bit
crazy if he does that or he's just lying
to us so as we go into this Last Arc of
the story let's take a look at all of
the unresolved issues that Oda has left
as always if you enjoy the one piece
content here on anime up World remember
to let us know by leaving a like on this
video and of course remember to
subscribe so that you never miss any of
our future videos as well but before we
talk about what's missing in one piece
let's talk about making sure nothing is
missing from you with keeps you might
not know this because we are always
using the anime uproar Avatar but both
animac and I have pretty luxurious Mains
going on and our hair is extremely
important to us but while we might have
it lucky people like my brother are
already beginning to thin up top and
actually he's been using heaps for about
a year with pretty great results so I'm
super excited to be working with them
for those who don't know keeps is an
online subscription service that
delivers clinically proven treatment for
combating your hair loss directly to
your door these are both affordable and
completely personalized specifically for
you all while offering 24 7 expert
support if you need it listen two-thirds
of men will begin to experience hair
loss before they even turn 35 and once
you're bald it's kind of game over but
with keeps you can help prevent slow or
even reverse some of the loss that
you're experiencing and that's why it's
so important to get ahead of it keeps
has everything that your hair needs and
they help you stay on track by reminding
you when your supply is running low or
when you would need a refill so whether
you're trying to prevent hair loss grow
it in a bit faster or thicker or just
try to take better care of your hair in
general remember that keeps has you
covered hair loss stops with keeps and
to get 50 off your first order you can
go to keeps.com anime uproar or click
the link in the description that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash anime uproar okay
for the most part I'm gonna be going
through things in more or less
chronological order but let's clear out
the most obvious and biggest questions
right off the bat firstly of course we
still don't know what the one piece is
and since animac has covered his
theories on this and talked that topic
to death recently we're just gonna be
skipping that one here after that we
have the straw hat dreams Zorro
obviously needs to become the best
swordsman in the world and to do so he
needs to either surpass or defeat mihawk
or do so for anyone who happens to do
that first there's of course the big fan
theory that shiryu will use his clear
clear fruit to get an advantage on
mihawk and win that way but that's of
course just a theory and not one I'm
super big on anyways Sanji of course
needs to find the all-blue Nami needs to
create a chart of the whole world
Chopper is doctoring or whatever he's up
to Frankie's ship needs to reach the end
of the grand line Robin needs to
understand the secrets of the Void
Century Jean Bay needs to unite fishmen
and humanity and both Luffy and Brooke
need to get back to laboon finally Luffy
of course also needs to give his straw
hat back to Shanks and while these two
get together we can probably throw in
usop reuniting with his father yasa but
I think that covers all of the big in
your face ones after those the first
real loose end takes place in logtown
but we're introduced to a few threads
that we still haven't followed through
in any meaningful way for example why
does tashigi look like kawina is there
going to be a payoff there I think it
would be a very strange choice to have
them look so similar for it to have such
an impact on Zorro and then never
address it and speaking of tashigi we
also don't know all of the grade swords
that she is looking for yet I doubt that
we're gonna learn or see all of the
lower tier swords but I would think that
we're at least going to see the 12
Supreme grade swords of which we've only
seen whitebeard's murakumogiri Rogers
Ace and mihawks yoru and this does kinda
make sense since as we approach the end
of the series we'll probably be meeting
with deadlier and dead leader swordsman
just based based on the power
progression of the series I do however
think it's pretty interesting that we
didn't see any of these Supreme blades
in kaido or big mom's crew staying on
the topic of Swords we need to see the
shodai kitetsu as we've seen the nidai
and Sunday kotetsu at this point and it
would be a little bit strange to only
have the third and second iteration of
the famous blade make an appearance
logtown also introduced us to Dragon the
most wanted man in the world we need to
learn what his Bounty is what his true
intentions are what that greened wind
that seems to follow him is and of
course if it's related to him having a
devil fruit and finally he obviously
needs to meet Luffy at some point or
another the last thing that really needs
to be addressed in logtown is Smoker's
pursuit of Luffy be it finally capturing
him or accepting that some Pirates
aren't evil there needs to be some kind
of resolution to this plot thread there
could also be a plot point where he
becomes a high-ranking marine and they
kind of leave an open ending for him
pursuing Luffy but I'm not super crazy
about that one from here most things
have been dealt with up until drum
Kingdom where we meet kareja who first
mentions the will of D which like what
is the will of D and how does kareja of
all people know about it little garden
only really leads us to the need for
usop to visit elbath and to become a
great warrior of the sea and I guess we
have the question of if Dory and bragi
ever return home now that they realize
that their argument just doesn't really
matter prior to recent events in wano
alabasta gave us the question of where
is pluton of course we now do know the
location what we don't know is the
nefertari's original role as World
Nobles specifically during the void
Century it is great that vivi's
ancestors left marijua but what were
these upstanding Celestial dragons doing
during the void century alabasta is also
the first time that we see Zone fruits
fused with inanimate objects we later
see this with funk freed and a few
others but most importantly is how they
all tie into vegapunk and his research
this is kind of the beginning of the
question of who he is and what his goals
are and this will constantly be brought
up throughout the series anime filler
point but there's also the pony glyph
that Luffy and Zorro find underground in
alabasta I know it's not canon but I'm
just curious as to what could have been
on it I wouldn't want this to like
appear in an episode or anything but
like maybe an SBS joke response from Oda
would be pretty fun over on Jaya we get
my favorite unresolved point in the
entire series the one I'm most excited
to see followed through as Luffy Zorro
and Nami leave Blackbeard Nami asks who
he is and both Luffy and Zorro correct
her saying that Blackbeard is not a he
but a they and of course this leading
into the whole Cerberus Theory and
opening a gajillion questions about
Blackbeard we also have the moment
between the feet and the gorosei and
like all of these characters are more or
less blank sheets to us we don't really
know anything about lafitte's devil
fruit and we don't know who the girls
say really are or how they specifically
were chosen for their positions finally
Bellamy mentions the lost city of gold
the one piece and the emerald City we
know the first two are real so it's
pretty reasonable to assume that the
Emerald City will be too there is of
course the theory that God Valley is the
Emerald City because the shape of the
island but this is obviously unconfirmed
up in Sky Pia and the biggest loose end
that we have here is of course anal we
know that he made it to the moon and
that he has all his little automata
homies but where is he going from here
skypeia also had our first mention of
pyrobloin the material that gives C
prism stone its abilities and we don't
really have a full explanation on how
that works yet either but I'm assuming
once we learn more about vegapunk we'll
get that explained to us as well soon
after all this we have aokiji mentioning
that GARP did him a favor but we don't
really know much about that Furthermore
with aokiji's current position where
does that leave his relationship with
GARP water 7 showed us that there was a
giant egg on the Oro Jackson which why
what is it is it a dragon egg if so
where is the dragon now and any zlabi
gives us several Loose Ends the biggest
of which being the ancient Kingdom what
happened to it why its name is so
important and where was it located Jabra
the wolf guy in cp9 mentions that there
are devils living inside of the devil
fruits and that the reason you can't eat
two of them is because the Devils will
fight inside of you and that'll cause
you to explode or something I doubt this
will be exactly on the mark but we might
have some kind of plot point about this
in the future or at least learn the
origin of where this idea comes from
Frankie of course Burns pluton's plans
but does he have them memorized we know
where pluton is now so even if not we do
have access to the ship around this
point we start learning a bit more about
the Revolutionary Army as well however
even to this day we only really know
that they exist we don't have a lot of
information on what they've actually
done outside of reverie and very little
about the organization other than their
members and that they oppose the world
government has been given to us
Blackbeard's devil fruit is finally
revealed in this fight with Ace here
Blackbeard mentions that he has a logia
fruit however it doesn't allow him to
turn into his element for protection and
instead actually makes him more
vulnerable to damage which is
interesting because it's the only logia
to work this way much like how katakuri
has a special paramecia that acts
similar to a logia Blackbeard seems to
have a special logia that works like a
paramecia on top of that Blackbeard's
devil fruit seems to allow him to turn
off devil fruit users Powers when he
touches them so it's definitely
incredibly strong and with the current
events in one piece it raises the
question of if this allows him to turn
off the connection that Luffy has with
joyboy through his devil fruit we later
learned that Blackbeard has been on
whitebeard's ship since he was a child
and memorized the devil fruit reference
book because he was looking for a
specific devil fruit but why was he
looking for this one and was he given a
nudge in the right direction from
someone someone possibly like zebic many
of Thriller Bark's Loose Ends have been
resolved fairly recently but there is
still the matter of the giant Shadows
that we saw it don't seem to be like the
Shadows of the people from sky islands
that we saw and instead they look like
these ominous monsters belonging in the
Florian triangle while they don't matter
in the grand scheme of things I'd still
like to see them addressed that said
they could be something like massive sea
Kings as they are based on the Umi Bozo
and this could tie them into Shira
hoshi's power and possibly towards the
end of the story sabodi gave us the
pacifistas but their role in the story
seems to be reaching its peak as we're
getting the seraphim now and we can
probably assume that the seraphim were
the ultimate goals for vegapunk when he
started experimenting on Kuma we also
need these supernovas at this point and
wano expands on many of them but we
still don't know the devil fruit names
for Bonnie or a Rouge we know Bonnie can
change people's ages we know uruge can
grow but we don't really know much else
about what they can do Bonnie seems like
she's going to be playing a bigger role
as we go towards the end of the series
as she has ties with Kuma but a Rouge is
just a mystery in general and on the
note of Bonnie being connected to Kuma
we know that he was the king of sorbet
Kingdom but we don't know exactly what
her connection to that was and why she
seemed so dead set on saving him
obviously in sabahori we also meet the
celestial dragons which brings up more
questions about the void Century we also
met Shockey whose history was just
revealed to us although I'm sure there's
more to the story and I would still like
to see more information on killer and
kid as they seem to have a pretty
similar relationship to Luffy and Zorro
impel down and marineford seemed to be
the first big climaxes in one piece the
ending of the first era in preparation
for the new world it meant that a lot of
storylines were coming to a close while
new ones were beginning and of those new
ones my favorite is crocodiles history
obviously he has some beef with
Whitebeard but more importantly is what
secret ivankov had that made Crocodile
so scared I would also love to get more
information on Shanks and kaido's
meeting at this time in the show I don't
think this really justifies being called
a loose end but this does seem to be
something that was worked out and not
made into to a full-fledged War so more
information would be really awesome on
to Whitebeard though just before he dies
he mentions that sengoku fears the
coming war that would engulf the world
and this is pretty crazy because they
were currently in one of the biggest
Wars that we know of with Marine Forge
seeing a yonko fleet Take On The World
Government and later in wano we see two
yonko coming together to fight the
supposed fifth Emperor who was teaming
up with supernovas the mink tribe the
samurai of wano and like anyone else
they could get on their team and even
that remained an isolated incident so
something uncomparably bigger seems to
be on the wave than these wars we've
seen and here we also get the first
instance of something being weird with
Shanks he seems to have enough leverage
to tell Marines to stand down he got
kaido to retreat he later walks into the
guru says office whatever shanks's deal
is it seems like his position is someone
who no one else is allowed to disagree
with no one else is allowed to challenge
which is strange because even among the
yonko he's always had the lowest
bounties at least until the new yonko
were introduced during the time skip we
don't get too much to worry about but we
do still need to learn what's going on
with zoro's eye and what the purpose of
tequila wolf is when we return to Saba
ODI we meet Caribou a character who is
terrible I don't know too many people
who like him but who does seem to have
something interesting going on Caribou
has been noted to talk about the ancient
weapons as well as mentioning some kind
of benefactor that is sharing
information about these weapons with of
course all these being located now
except for Uranus it's also around this
time that we start seeing people attempt
to kidnap Robin or at least her imposter
at first however later Neko mamushi
mentions this as well we see people
watching over her constantly big mom
telling kaido to kill everyone except
her Rob Lucci obviously putting in the
order to capture her in wano and at some
point it seems like we're we're going to
be saving her again likely in regards to
her being able to read the road
poneoglyphs of course we also learn
about Roger originally having the straw
hat which he gave to Shanks and then
eventually that was given to Luffy what
is this straw Hat's importance and did
someone give it to Roger in the same way
he passed down it seems to have some
kind of symbol of Legacy so I doubt that
it will actually be given back to Shanks
so if Luffy is going to pass it on who
is he going to give it to and most
importantly what does this have to do
with the giant straw hat in marijua on
to Fishman Island where we have the Noah
the ship that Joy boy was going to use
to bring fish men back to the surface we
definitely need to know more about that
story and I'm super curious as to how it
will be used going forward and back to
this idea of Joy boy who was he really
what did he do what was his role in the
void century and finally what does it
mean that Luffy is now Joy boy and
speaking of Luffy and Fishman Island
Madame Charolais ability to see into the
future is an interesting one that has
never been explained it doesn't seem to
be a devil fruit but all the same she
saw a prophecy of Luffy destroying
Fishman Island and that needs to come
true although I think most fans believe
this will happen with the red line being
destroyed thus creating the all-blue
taking down marijua and reuniting laboon
with our Lads all at once so we might
see that happen as the story continues
finally for Fishman Island we do get
some attention being drawn to the voice
of all things here while we have seen a
few moments where it has come into place
since then the big payoff definitely
hasn't seemed to happen yet over in Punk
Hazard we see the man-made dragon and we
know dragons in general went extinct in
the world in one piece a point which was
raised and has yet to really be
impactful gigantism experiments is also
something that hasn't been super
followed up on but it does seem to be in
line with the kuma experiments the king
experiments and involved in the creation
of the new seraphim that we saw though
again we still know very little about
this overall as I mentioned earlier
alkiji leaves the Marines and we don't
really know what's up with him now
although he does seem to have some
connection with Blackbeard which we hear
about in dressrosa speaking of dressrosa
we overthrow doflamingo there which
means that the entire underworld
organization that he ran now has a
massive power vacuum supposedly
affecting the underworld as a whole
something which might be addressed as we
did learn more about the underworld
Emperors people like stucy Morgan's
dufeld umit drug Pelco and giberson in
dressrosa we were also introduced to the
new Admirals and while we now know more
about fujitora and greenbull we still
don't know their histories all that well
other than they recently joined the
Marines however what's interesting is
that neither of them seem to have been
Vice Admirals so where did they come
from before the Marines and why are they
so powerful now cp0 was introduced with
some familiar faces from cp9 but there
are also several members that we don't
know anything about even a few names
that still haven't been revealed even
years later much like Blackbeard's they
loose end another of my favorites to
talk about is laws ape ape know me and
specifically the immortality surgery
which involves giving his own life to
make someone else Immortal now there's
two reasons that this could have been
brought up in the series firstly law is
eventually going to give his own life to
make someone else Immortal pretty
straightforward second and probably more
likely the previous user of the ope ope
Nomi used the immortality surgery on
someone else for example possibly eem or
zevik and thus characters who could
still be present in the story Dopey also
alludes to this power allowing him to
use something called The Treasure of
marijua to control the world we don't
know what this treasure is but it might
be some kind of weapon meant for
conquests or something that might
Empower him in some other way back to
the topic of law though his mentor
Corazon tells him that the d-clan are
the natural enemies of God which there's
a whole history about that that we still
need to learn more about just the d-clan
in general because this is a pretty
ominous line to never be flushed out
finally for dressrosa we had the
creation of the straw hat Grand Fleet
and the promise to come to Luffy's Aid
if he needs it and if kaido and big mom
together isn't enough of a reason for
this to happen I can only imagine what
it's going to take the Zoe Arc gave us
Edward Weevil calling himself
whitebeard's son and becoming a warlord
only for the Warlords to dissolve
slightly afterwards which like what's up
with that who is this guy and is he ever
going to matter before Road ponoglyphs
are up next and one combined they form
an X that marks the spot where laughtail
can be found one was found in the whale
Tree on zou one was in kaido's
possession one was in big mom's
possession and the straw hats have a
copy of all of these however the fourth
Road pornoglyph vanished from the sea
forest in Fishman Island over 25 years
ago with no one seeming to know where it
went went I'm not sure if this next
Point needs to be addressed but we did
also hear about lodestar Island the
point at which the log poses reach their
natural ending we still know nothing
about why Blackbeard attacked the
revolutionaries at baltago however we do
know that they were stopped after
clashing with Cipher pull finally
zunesha itself had apparently committed
some kind of crime and is forced to walk
endlessly as punishment zunesha clearly
has some kind of connection with joy boy
so that might be related to the crime
hole cake Island brought up the
backstory of big mom and her ties to
elbeth which we still need to visit plus
we learned about Prince Loki as well and
I'd be surprised if he didn't come up
when we reach elbaf we still need to see
what happened to the sun Pirates and to
Caesar Clown and possibly need a reunion
between Sanji and pudding especially now
that big mom has been taken out and
putting essentially is free to make her
own choices another interesting topic
from this era to me is the lineage
factor in Devil fruits this idea that
part of the previous user is carried
into the new fruit you see this possibly
with the Nika fruit but also with Ace
and Sabo and at least in my head Canon
we also see this between Blackbeard and
possibly zebic finally we get our
mention of the dawn of the world all we
know about this is that the minks are
waiting for it it involves the pony
glyphs and supposedly the straw hats are
the ones to bring it in Yamato also
tells momonosuke that he needs to
survive to see it I am very interested
to see what this means although I'd
imagine that it refers to the day that
the world government gets taken down and
the Darkness from the void century is
lifted next up the God Valley incident
just all of it what happened to rocks
did he die there why was Shanks in a
treasure chest what happened to the
island why are the celestial dragons
there there are so many questions and we
only know that Roger was there to fight
with GARP against zebic speaking of
things we know very little about imsama
what is their deal I get why they're
targeting Luffy Blackbeard and
shirohoshi but why Vivi also how long
has Ian been in control of the world is
he Immortal what's with the giant straw
hat that he's looking at who else knows
about him aside from the Goro say the
list goes on and on and speaking of who
knows what Shanks visits the gorosei to
talk about a certain pirate then Having
learned that Luffy defeats kaido and big
mom decides that it's time to head for
the one piece are these events connected
and was that certain pirate Blackbeard
or did he mean Luffy finally why does he
have so much leeway where he can walk
into the gorosei's office no questions
asked we still need to know more about
what happened with the revolutionaries
attack on mariswa we were told that Sabo
killed Cobra but like doubtful I'm sure
this is going to be addressed in the
next few chapters at least slightly we
learned that doflamingo is being hunted
by assassins this might be related to
him knowing about The Treasure of
marijua but will he really be safe at
the bottom of impel down or will someone
be able to Target him just like Luffy
was able to get to the bottom finally
for every Psy leaves Kano Kingdom which
I don't particularly care about but it
was brought up so it might matter
eventually and that brings us to wano
firstly what happened to Moria when he
visited hachinosu is he still alive did
Blackbeard steal his fruit if he did
does that mean that he has an army of
zombies yet one of the bigger questions
is why did Roger laugh at laughtail we
know that he was there too early for
something and it seems that both Joy boy
and the mermaid princess need to be
involved there so now that those two are
here what are they needed for exactly
when Luffy enters gear Fifth and becomes
Joy boy sunesha mentions the drums of
Liberation is this related to the dawn
of the world lunarians are brought up
here with King and it seems like the
experiments they did on him allowed for
the creation version of the new
pacifista the seraphim will they all be
as durable as he was will they have the
same weaknesses and vulnerabilities as
he did how will Yamato and Momo come
back into the story now that Luffy is
leaving without them when will Yamato
finally set sail like she wanted to this
whole time and speaking of teammates in
general now that the Luffy and law
Alliance is over what will their
relationship be like will law get
revenge for the immense therapy that he
needs having to deal with the straw hats
for so long wano of course is under new
leadership but how will it recover from
the years of pollution and poison from
Orochi and kaido and what's going to
happen to all the people who became
failed smile users will this be part of
Chopper's dream to become the cure-all
doctor and last for wano we now know the
location of pluton the existence of old
wano and what it means to truly open the
country how will all of these come into
play in the coming arts and finally and
most importantly just who is sniper King
and where is sniper Island these are all
the Loose Ends that I could think of I
am more than certain I missed some of
them but one piece is a pretty long
Series so if I miss some let me know in
the comments give me a hand and let's
fill out this list together if you
enjoyed this video remember to leave a
like and of course subscribe for more
future content from this channel you can
always check out my own channel
axelbeats if you're looking to support
me directly or get more content from me
and I want to give another huge thank
you to keeps for sponsoring this video
remember to check them out in the
description down below until next time
though thank you guys so much for
watching and I hope you all stay
excellent